hello welcome to this video playing FM
no sorry I am hyper Xiao so I had an
idea maybe play the exchange rate and
sometimes struggle a bit with black
they're normally while try to make it
interesting and make it interesting for
the other side so let's seem hyper Zhao
in the liquor are paciencia Philippines
and I'd like to trade this that seems I
can do that now pretty pretty quickly so
night to d5 or night h5 sometimes
interesting so I don't do that yet it's
96 good
I think it is going yeah that's it's
what to what to do here I can also take
g7
I can take c7 hmm interesting and by the
way if I take with this where is the
root going now I'm getting somewhere I
cannot go to you seven right so let's
rock the eight made I think it loses the
exchange that's really weird black
resigns yeah well surprisingly could win
there with this opening so let's see
what happened I'm well I'm not an expert
about this particular line but Bishop t6
I think should help me because I want to
play this trade anyway and now he cannot
avoid it and I get the night into the
game pretty quickly and I'm not sure
maybe it started with 97 here I mean I
felt this is a bit annoying I mean the
real problem is Bishop c6 of course but
I felt this is a somewhat annoying
position already maybe this one you have
to develop the night somehow get
assistance losers straight away the
point being there Shaq make this is a
very unusual check made after 16 moves
so we added that work quite well am the
rule open exchange ok guys thanks for
watching